The Joe Rogan experience,
your initial questioning is how do people kind of lose their collective minds?
It every once in a while in history and a part of the answer is if you start a
kind of vicious circle of denouncing people and then denouncing people who don't
denounce,
people were denouncing people who call the whistle on a and other people
denouncing people,
then you can get a kind of circle of terror where no one wants.
Everyone is so afraid of being denounced that they wanted to.
Now first Stalinist Soviet Union is another example at Mao's China,
and that's somehow some,
one of the ways in which dictators could often,
uh,
enforce their power by habits turning the citizens against each other.
So everyone's denouncing everyone else out of fear that they'll be an announced
first
going on right now in North Korea,
right?
Absolutely.
Yeah.
North Korea,
they have this thing where they each have to report on each other.
Like when people are together,
they report on each other for different things that they did that were
violations of whatever code
they follow up.
Absolutely.
And so governments know how to explain it,
but it isn't just governments,
it can happen spontaneously too.
It's a weird human trait,
isn't it?
It is.
It's a combination of a kind of a human trait and a kind of dynamic when you
have a kind of a network of people and they all are,
are kind of trapped and no one can be the first person to escape from this
vicious circle because they don't want to be the one who is denounced it,
imprisoned and tortured or whatever the consequence may be.
What do you think,
where do you think,
if you think at all about this,
where do you think this is all headed?
Like especially in terms of social media and certainly it's hard to tell,
but I,
you,
you mentioned the possibility that there's been such a growing recognition of
the problem that we will mount a response that it'll just seem ridiculous of the
outrage mob once it's recognized that there are outraged mobs and virtual
signaling fanatics.
Uh,
once we have a label for them,
once we know that it's a thing,
a,
it'll seem so ridiculous that people will be less tempted to do it.
I mean,
that's the optimistic outcome.
I never really had followed his political or is his public speaking type life.
So I was like,
holy crap,
this guy is pretty dialed in.
It's probably the plan it takes over when he might retire,
he might,
I mean he's 40 so he's just getting his feet under in that world.
And trump dynasty just like they did with the buses.
That's right.
Just know all of the Clintons claim.
Once you're in there,
it's like,
that's all they want.
Isn't that interesting?
It's crazy.
But he,
I would feel.
I mean man.
Well that's a good guy.
I wished that don junior was running for president.
Yeah,
he's don junior is very reasonable.
Oh Man.
Totally,
totally.
It's funny if he,
if he says one thing wrong,
one thing,
one slip up of a word,
which by the way,
everybody does every day.
I do it every day.
Yeah,
me too.
One,
one slip up of the word Corey Knowlton one fuck up like that.
And then this,
I mean,
you see all this,
this magnified,
ridiculous hate that comes his way and the,
uh,
the attacks against him,
people right now listening to this,
probably yelling at them because they're fucking Joseph Ford.
Here's the show.
Here's a dose yet.
Yeah,
they,
it's,
I mean,
it is really hard not to get pissed off.
What's really hard to be unbiased.
It's really hard to have perspective.
I don't think anybody does a good job as president.
I've never seen a single person to do it well.
But really my drug of choice was meth back in that day.
That was what I really liked.
That was actually what I was addicted to at one point and I ended up going to
jail and that was what got me out of addiction.
I didn't realize I was addicted until I was in jail.
So what made you realize that when you were in jail?
Uh,
just,
I just couldn't stop thinking about it and just won it and just,
I mean I didn't get,
have like,
like,
um,
like cold sweats or anything.
I don't think that happens with purse,
but
I mean I was just like,
the couldn't stop thinking about it,
man.
I was like,
dude,
like just a lot of that anger was coming out.
I was just like,
God,
what the fuck?
I wanted to fight everybody.
I was like,
somebody gave me something,
you know?
And Wow.
Yeah.
It was just really terrible experience,
but probably only lasted three or four days.
Not even,
maybe not even that.
And then you came out of it.
Yeah,
I mean I was just like a able to accept my fate and,
and deal with it.
What does it feel like to be on meth?
You have to take adderall.
I'd never taken an adderall.
No,
I'm
pretty similar to adderall.
Right.
It's like adderall.
I mean that's the closest I would say
how many you're high,
but you don't have that euphoria more than anything.
Just to,
excuse me.
Just an extreme sense of euphoria.
Just everything is beautiful.
But then men,
soon as you start to lose that a little bit,
you just itch for it.
So bad man.
So bad.
Like you just want it again.
You don't want to sleep.
You like your teeth would be grinding and you're just like,
oh,
you're just tensing up all your muscles.
I got,
I got to get more of that.
You know.
Now when you're working out at all back then.
No,
no.
Well I take,
well not working out like I should be.
So again,
I,
I was angry a lot of times,
like I'd be at a party that this was a common thing I'd be at like a party or
just doing drugs,
whatever.
And I just started getting look at everybody like I don't like none of you.
And I would just walk outside and I would go for a run.
I'd run five,
six miles,
come back and be like,
all right,
give me another line or whatever.
Wow.
Yeah.
Um,
you won't run and then come back.
Yeah.
And then sometimes I would,
I would fight people,
you know,
that was very,
very
common if you call that working out.
And we did
this particular time in my life.
I was.
Let me see what we got here.
Billionaire Air Wyatt.
Coke makes shirts about money.
I drank blood this morning.
Wait a minute.
It's their shirts are about money.
Can you.
Can I see those pictures again?
That looks like pink handcuffs with keys.
How has that about money?
Because that's what I paid for.
Paid.
Handcuffed.
Or you are you allowed to show these videos of him like dancing around and his
shirts and it's actually been removed.
It's unavailable.
Somebody's got it.
Dude.
It's the weirdest fucking shit.
Everywhere.
He brings his whimsical ideas to life with his retina blasting shirt.
Brand.
Why at Ingram.
So why at Ingram is his shirt brand?
Yeah.
But you got to look up an interview with him because he says shit like daddy
told me I could do whatever I want.
And I am looking at chick wounds.
That is girl big.
That bigger.
God Damn.
I prove
I'm on his side.
If a guy who looks like that can get a girl who looks like that,
you go,
boy,
what am I a man hater?
Huh?
Am I one of these asshole men?
Shoot other men down.
I'm not a guy.
He didn't even bother even think once about losing weight.
I'm not either.
I'm just using weight.
Look at my Zeros.
I'm just using that as an example of the progeny of billionaires like these
people are like,
this is something that this shit's spilling out of the mansions man.
Like,
look at this says here,
blessed this oafish,
coke air and his hideous shirts.
He's a flamboyant guy and now we're talking about them.
Good for you,
sir.
I'm sorry.
He's smart.
He's.
He looks like the guy who sold the dinosaurs in Jurassic Park.
Remember the dude?
What's his name?
The guy from the Newman Newman.
He looks like Newman and he's banging a 10 man to get the fuck out.
He also looks like he's been spending a lot of time in the skull and bones come
coughing.
I'm not satisfied.
I haven't absorbed all the energy of the come into my being.
So you.
You take their blood and then they.
What do they find it to the lab?
You want to look at cortisol levels,
how the stresses you want to look at white blood count,
see if they're fighting any infections.
Uh,
you know,
there's always a no in her case,
there's always something,
a lot of the animals are in fact on value and a lot of different sites.
Tons.
What that,
that is like rampant use in,
uh,
in,
in the,
in aquariums.
What volume.
Yeah.
I'm reeling.
Accused me of stealing value and in fact,
in the lawsuit as well,
which is absolutely not true because this.
Is this used everywhere or is it just the greenland?
Greenland.
Seaworld everywhere.
Yes,
absolutely.
Like dolphins.
Dolphins are on volume all the time.
Sure.
When I was,
when I was,
when I left marine land,
I had the agreement again.
I left fairly amicably considering the situation,
but you know,
I wanted to play my cards right.
And murraylands owner called me back in specifically to help a dolphin.
And it was the theater of course,
the waste that was in the daily mail.
Let's,
what's the other one?
The Dodo.
A good one.
Buzzfeed.
Let's go with buzzfeed.
Seaworld puts its whales on valium volume like drug documents say Jesus.
Fuck.
Those documents are from a lawsuit between marine land and sea world where
seaworld sued marine land.
See on Ontario at seaworld sued marine.
Yeah.
The old Benzodiazepines,
I'm telling you,
wow.
Trainers give their orchids on.
Austin was killer whales.
The psychoactive jug,
Benzodiazepine,
according to the sworn affidavit filed in order to Ontario Superior Court of
Justice in dispute between the park company to rival company marine land over
the transport of a prize.
Killer whale.
I.
Keiko,
I can't go.